all right everybody we're back janine
turner
is uh coming up in uh just a minute
it'll be great to have her on the
program
excuse me conan andy oh hey uh
folks it's uh it's todd he's one of our
security guards here at the program i'm
sorry to bother you during the show but
uh there's this woman out here who
doesn't have a ticket
and she keeps insisting on coming in
anyway
well you can't interrupt the show i mean
you'll just have to tell her to come
back another time
well i would tell her to come back andy
but she keeps claiming she's your little
sister
hi yeah no that is uh andy's little
sister stacy hey there stacy hi hi conan
yeah we uh we didn't know you were
coming today but it's it's really nice
to see you
again it is
uh stacy remember how we decided maybe
it was better if you didn't come to the
show for a while
remember that yeah i know andy i'm sorry
the last time i was here i
totally spazzed out like a super door
well it's it's okay stacy yeah
you were you were upset because you have
a crush on conan and
you found out he doesn't feel the same
way
andy wants to go like tell russia or
something
look andy andy didn't mean to embarrass
you i i just
i just don't want to see you get hurt
that's all
you don't
stacy last time you were here you got
pretty upset
look since then i have
grown so much emotionally
stacey that was four weeks ago that was
a month
i know that but with the help of both
transcendental meditation and my judy
bloom books
have come to terms with my feelings for
conan and i now know
that i need to concentrate on boys my
own age
so i brought some pictures to show you
guys
this is my room when i used to be
obsessed with corn
and here's my room now check it out
there's a sign in there it says i love
hansen yeah yeah
i love the middle one yeah yeah but
stacy your room is still basically a
shrine to conan okay i appreciate your
concern andy
but i want you to know that i am totally
glad that conan already has a girlfriend
you are sure without her there'd be
nobody to compare me to
and then you would never realize that i
am your true ultimate soul mate
what don't fight it conan
we all need to experience the rejection
of a relationship
in order to make room for the arrival of
true love oh wait uh
tre tracy i don't i don't think you you
you you are stacy i'm sorry
okay look i know i don't
i don't think you understand i i really
am flattered but i like you as a friend
and only as a friend
what come on don't you
think we could be friends
oh yeah sure
let's be friends
i'll tell you what why i just sit down
and watch my
friend do his little show
all right have a seat all right i'm sure
this gentleman won't mind moving
sir
no i'm sorry i i waited all day for this
seat
get out of here musclehead break you in
half where the twix bar
moving
take it take it easy
take it easy stacy you shut your hole
richter
i got a sock full of batteries with your
name on it
come on oh my oh my god
i'll tell you i am out of here everybody
but i promise you i'll be
back and when i do the walls will
tremble in the wake of my
fury and you oh brian you will
hang drawn and quartered on the frame
ropes of my
vengeance are you there god
it's me stacy
stacy stacy
stacy stop doing that okay
i don't even know what that is now i'm
sorry i upset you
don't you understand i i really like you
i'm sorry too i mean for some
puberty is a sign of awakening but for
me
puberty is a raging sea of psychosexual
turmoil
well wait a minute well then well then
why don't you just sit down and and
we'll get you some popcorn and then i
can't eat popcorn just get stuck in my
breakfast all right okay just take it
easy we're gonna
take a little break we'll take care of
we'll think of something we'll be right
back